there's the dh aj pollock hitting here
to right center did it pretty well can
anybody get back there le castro going
back and
calhoun made the catch and gets it back
in seeger back to first base two outs
nice play out there le castro's laughing
about it right now but you got two guys
are going all out over there on the
outfield yeah those two guys aren't
going to stop for anything the dodgers
get a couple of walks here in the first
and that'll bring up max munson fly ball
into shallow center
and there is
la castro for the catch to retire the
side so
the dodgers get two on with a pair of
walks they'll leave them walker
bueller's going to come at him with the
hard stuff about 85
and since he has been hot he has avoided
walks and he has avoided the extra base
hit where's christian walker as walker
swings and misses foul tips it into the
glove of austin warranty and he's over
gavin luck stepping in he's four for 27
hitting a buck 48. it's a small left
field sends peralta back over his head
it keeps going and gone
gavin lux launches an opposite field
home run his first of the season and the
dodgers strike first in arizona luke
weaver that's the ninth home run he has
uh surrendered in 34 innings seven of
them to left-handed batteries
back-to-back two-out singles from
bellinger and muncie and they've got him
cornered and taylor who struck out in
his first at-bat and it's popped up in
the center
but castro's there under it and he makes
a catch so green light for taylor and an
easy pop-up helps out weaver on the
diamondbacks marshall had a nice series
against san francisco he got his first
runs batted him then at his first big
league home run marshall swings hits it
down the left field line getting pretty
well toward that corner out there and
this ball hits the pole it's gone
opposite field home run down the left
field line for far show and the
diamondbacks have tied the ball game at
one how about the elevation on that ball
down the line i mean balls are just
flying out here bueller even after that
watching that ball he just starts
shaking his head like how did that ball
get out arizona at first and third with
one away the two hitter could tell marte
on the ground to lux spins and double
clutches and the throw gets away
but castro's home rojas is in it third
and the diamondbacks have a 2-1 lead and
he made a nice play on this ball it was
hit really well by martay on the ground
and turns around and goes to nice easy
throw sets himself
and throws wide of course muncie didn't
help out much there yeah
in front for the first time here's
christian walker muncie backhands it
they go to second for one and that's all
they'll get as rojas comes in make it
three to one and it's three one d backs
let's see if they can get more cole
calhoun up now runner first two out
swings sits into the air to left going
back at it on the warning track on the
wall it's gone a home run
opposite field for cole calhoun and the
diamondbacks scored two more it's been a
five run inning and they're on top five
to one that one just kind of snuck out
here once he got up a five-run third
against bueller and he will exit the
ball game trailing five to one five
walks for the dodgers tonight two on
with one out corked on a line drive base
it into center
they will send pollock
he's in to score 5-2
rbi single chris taylor there's some of
that cheering you talked about with the
build-up coming from all these
opportunities they've had finally
breaking through here bases are loaded
for the nine-hitter barnes and a chopper
to marta and he throws onto first for
the out two on the other four to three
on the put out dodgers leave them loaded
first and third here batter is going to
be peralta facing the lefty david a
chopper to third here comes a runner to
the plate throw to second for what
dropped i think they're going to call
him out at second and lux is going to be
credited with the put out drop the ball
on the exchange a 6-2 diamondback ball
game two walks to the ending two on now
with one man out and alex will be the
hitter there's a ground ball up the
middle into center field for a base hit
rounding third
and on his way home is bellinger
an rbi single for gavin lux dodgers have
trimmed arizona's lead to six to three
two on one out dodgers down three in the
seventh rios hits one deep to right
center field that's over calhoun and
one run is in they're going to send
gavin lux here's the throw to the plate
he dropped the ball and it's a one-run
game
rios is second at 6-5 as he drives in a
pair that's going to ban with two on and
one out here left it over the plate base
it into center field rios coming in
throw heads to third the dodgers have
come from behind to tie it in the
seventh now the go ahead run 90 feet
away still just won out seeger and a
ground ball back up the mill great play
by rojas gets it out at first are they
going to see if
rojas had his foot on the bag as he
fielded this yeah maybe that's a double
play that gets him out of the inning and
prevents that run from scoring which is
an enormous call here because that's the
go ahead run it is a double play what a
play by rojas this game stays tied
chance to break this tie as rios comes
up ground ball down to first diving play
by walker underhands the giggle for the
out at first to end the inning walkers
save the day there and that'll turn the
dodgers away they leave three more
they've stranded 14 tonight potential
winning run at first in the form of the
speedy le castro who's got a good lead
there goes the runner the pitch is
outside the throw down not in time gets
away and la castro will go to third and
he will be there with two men out throw
comes back in le castro coming to the
plate and he is tagged out oh my
goodness the bug got away and tim just
kept coming and they threw him out of
the plane he was out by ten feet and
we're gonna go extras tonight chris
taylor runners at first and third
bouncing ball left side escobar misplays
it and the dodgers take the lead and he
feuded it cleanly pollock was probably
going to be out at home
the dodgers catch a break and lead 7-6
in the tent
and gavin looks coming up
that's a high fly ball to right field
calhoun's going back on it gavin looks
with a second home run of the night a
skyscraping three-run shot against lopez
and they've broken it open in the 10.
they're gonna try to go up with another
four-seamer
launches one that's gonna go kristin
walker
hold the phone that's his six and it's
ten to eight
two and two on david peralta up the
middle that's gonna get into center as
kebar is home an rbi for peralta and
wyatt matheson will get a chance
he struck him out and that ends this
roller coaster